involvement with the super pac american
crossroads
thank you
they're about
a little less than two months left
before the election and in many ways
this is the time this book was
uh designed for because as we enter
these last few months this is when the
election really gets going and uh to me
that one of the great untold stories is
this is not just uh obama versus romney
it's obama versus karl rove
and he's been behind the scenes the
whole time
and uh
he has put together
over 1 billion dollars that will be
spent in these last two months and it's
gonna be we in new york here you're not
going to see much of it it'll be spent
in the battleground states
and uh his super he's become king of the
super pacs
um he has
when you put together his money with the
money that romney has raised and the
republican national committee it's a
total of about
1.8 billion dollars
to put that in perspective in 08 mccain
had 375 million to spend so this is a
factor of five and and you're going to
start seeing it coming out now
and the other thing is i wanted to
discuss about him is that who is he
really what does he do he's a political
operative well how does he operate what
does he really do
uh and and i talked to a couple of
sources about that and one who was one
of his victims said you know there's a a
dark and terrible beauty about what he
does
and i i had another source who was a ci
a former cia agent named larry johnson
who told me that
you know caa could learn an awful lot
from karl rove
and uh the way he he has deniability and
all these operations he does he's both
very very visible uh he he has something
like a 70 name recognition in the united
states that's
up there with justin bieber
uh but uh we don't really know what he
does most people don't and and and when
you go back over his history and look at
the things that are starting to unfold
in the election
uh
he has deniability at
lev one level after another
uh
to me the story uh became interesting in
a way because i think most people
thought karl rove was finished
in 2008 when when the bush presidency
started to come to an end
he had been forced out of the white
house in 2007
he was the prime target in the two
biggest scandals of the bush era the
valerie plaim affair and the united
states attorney scandal
bush left the white house with a 22
percent approval rating the lowest in
the history of the united states
and even
top republican strategists like ed
rollins said that his brand was tainted
forever no one would ever want to be a
business republican to work with karl
rove
and uh the fact of the matter is uh he
was back working again within a matter
of weeks
and
it became evident to me in 2010 early
2010 about a year after obama took
office
three things happened
the first
was
from the came from the united states
supreme court and i think no
person in the united states that i can
think of
has benefited more from the supreme
court than karl rove
two decisions one
in 2000 obviously was bush b gore which
put his candidate in the white house
and two
in 2010
the citizens united decision and that
opened the the floodgates for
contribution unlimited contributions in
many cases from secret sources with no
transparency whatsoever
that is just unprecedented in history
the second thing that happened was
michael steele running the republican
party and he sort of running into a
ditch and he couldn't raise a dime and
and it came to its nader early uh in
2010
uh you may recall there was a
revelation in los angeles
that uh the republican national
committee had been entertaining its
donors at a lesbian bondage street
themed strip club
uh and for the family party of family
values this did not work too well so
they could not raise a dime
and this gave rove his opening so in in
april
he had a luncheon at his house it was in
in washington dc on weaver terrace
it was co-hosted by ed gillespie a
former chair of the rnc
and they had about two dozen people over
and came away with tens and tens of
millions of dollars
and that luncheon alone gave them about
four times as much money as the entire
republican party
so rove was effectively establishing an
apparatus
that gave him an enormous amount of
power and authority with almost no
responsibility he reported to no one but
he had his hands on the purse strings
and this led
to the 2010 legislative elections they
raised a total
of 300 million dollars
and
swept congress they took 63 seats in the
house
and suddenly obama's big advantage was
gone he had no real authority
um
this
money so so the question is what did he
do with the money what is he going to do
with the money it's going to go into the
battleground states
and i i started to lo to look at what
he's going to do now
i decided to look what he had done in
the past and i found again and again
that a lot of it uh
really had not been reported in depth
um
we for one one thing i found that he had
was a was a huge technology apparatus
and i went to chattanooga tennessee
and i found a company called smart tech
i i saw rove
about a year ago in ohio and i asked him
about this company he told me he'd never
heard of it well
uh i find that hard to believe when
this is a company that has a rather
byzantine corporate history
but if you go through all the fronts
within fronts and the corporate changes
and find out who put up the original
money
the original money came from two very uh
wealthy republican donors named mercer
reynolds
and bill dewitt
and i researched them and in the 80s
they had uh bailed out george w bush uh
several times he
he
had three oil companies in the 80s that
went belly up and each time they came to
his rescue
uh they were also baseball royalty uh
bill dewitt owns uh st louis cardinals
uh and his father had owned the old
saint louis browns
and um
they gave
bush entre into his ownership in the in
the texas rangers which was the one
uh
the only lucrative investment he ever
made i mean he put in 600 000 and came
away with about 15 million dollars and
this company
smart tech which started out as quite a
legitimate technology company soon
became a republican operation
and it's all good and well that
republicans or conservative groups
should have their their uh
websites and so forth but this was very
unusual and i saw
uh george w bush 43.com was there uh the
republican national committee hosted its
websites later the swift boat veterans
for truth
hundreds and hundreds of conservative
groups were there again that's all all
fine and well but
it this company which is highly highly
partisan
also
over time acquired some contracts that i
i think probably not should not have
gone to to such a partisan company
and let me just say two of those
uh one was uh if you're in the white
house your emails according to the
presidential records act
are public documents
and they're supposed to be hosted
on whitehouse.gov
but rose made sure that his emails were
hosted on smart tech and that 80 of his
staffers who other people who worked
with him in the white house also had
their emails there so
when rove was investigated for
the valerie plame affair and again
in the u.s attorney scandal
suddenly 22 million emails were deleted
and these are all government documents
and and
they have never been found
so that that was one thing
he seems to have gotten away with
um
another thing was in 2004
smart tech played a central role in the
presidential election
and the secretary of state of each state
part of their job is to oversee a fair
and impartial election
and you may recall in the 2000 election
uh kathleen harris in florida
was
secretary of state of florida and she
also happened to play a central role in
the bush election and
there was considerable controversy over
that
well
a very similar thing happened in ohio in
2004 when where ken blackwell was
secretary of state
and again he was supposed to oversee a
fair and impartial election but he
happened also to be co-chair
of the bush cheney re-election committee
and he decided that uh to tabulate the
returns for the 2004 election the
secretary of state's computers weren't
enough and they needed to get another
set of consu computer servers so who did
he go to but smart tech
and smart tech's role in this is uh
raises a lot of an enormous amount of
very very interesting questions and i i
went through the returns with people who
studied this there were civil lawsuits
uh you could see when the returns came
in that night and what happened as that
night were on on i believe was november
2nd 2004 it was a very very close
election it was clear the election would
come down to who won florida who won
ohio these were the the last two key
battleground states
uh around 11 o'clock
the networks finally called it for
florida and that meant there was one
crucial state outstanding ohio
whoever won ohio would win the electoral
college
the exit polls were in and they showed
kerry winning ohio by 4.2 percent
uh suddenly millions of people started
logging on to the secretary of state's
computer
uh in ohio traffic went through the roof
it went up 700 percent that meant that
computers in chattanooga tennessee had
kicked in at 11 14 p.m
and suddenly
in county after county that reported
there were just these striking anomalies
in in the next 10 counties in a row
and this raises a lot of serious
questions about who actually won the
election uh i i went about as far as i
could in tr tracing this down
and
in terms of of pinning it down
uh
conclusively unfortunately there were
there were still some unanswered
questions and the reason for that
is that again and again
all the evidence vanished mysteriously
and there was a court order as a result
of one of the lawsuits to impound all
the ballots
but suddenly
over a million ballots
were damaged or disappeared
in 2006 a new secretary of state a
democratic secretary of state was
elected in ohio and she was about to
take office and went by
uh the her new offices just before she
formally took office and when she went
in she saw everyone there under the
direction of the old secretary of state
the republican ken blackwell was
shredding thousands and thousands of
documents
and finally
in this civil suit a man named mike
connell was scheduled to testify he'd
done one he'd been subpoenaed once and
uh deposed once and given one deposition
he was scheduled to give another and he
was rove cyber guru he supposedly had
all the answers
and uh on december 19th
uh 2008
uh his plane crashed i know pride
so there were a lot of unanswered
questions about that
um
i think when we get to the current uh
you know two other things i'd like to
talk about before we uh
uh open it up to questions um
one is
happened just two days ago a man named
don siegelman went to jail
and he was the former
governor of alabama
and the u.s attorney scandal i think is
something that was widely misunderstood
and people didn't really understand the
impact but it's one thing that karl rove
was heavily involved in
that that has a lasting lasting impact
today
and uh the scandal was widely reported
as that eight u.s attorneys lost their
jobs because they were not towing the
party line
but in fact i think there's a much
bigger scandal that really escaped
attention
and the and the question is
what about the u.s attorneys who were
towing the party line what were they
doing
and the answer is they were prosecuting
democrats
and i found uh in the first term of
bush's uh bush's first term alone over
200 politicians were were prosecuted
and
85
of them were democrats
and uh
you what what you found
don siegelman is probably the most
egregious example
he is two days ago he went to jail he's
going to serve
nearly seven years
and what he did is something that almost
every politician
has done is he gave an appointment it
happened to be a non-paying appointment
to a board of education
to
a campaign contributor he received
nothing personally
and the man in return got a
state position that he'd held before
under the republicans
but for that don
siegelman was prosecuted for bribery and
he was convicted
and he's already served seven months he
was out on appeal and now he's going
back for another
for nearly seven years
this is something george w bush did this
with more than a hundred
appointees it's sort of a commonplace
it's it's not the most
the prettiest part of our electoral
system but it's a common place for a big
campaign contributor to become an
ambassador
bush did it with over a hundred
of his appointees of course he was not
prosecuted but siegelman was manacled
was in a maximum security prison uh he
was at the democratic position uh
national convention in charlotte uh and
now uh just two days ago he he's gone
off to jail
the other thing that was part of the us
attorney scandal we're seeing again in
this election and uh a u.s attorney by
the name of david iglesias in new mexico
who lost his job
in in 2004 he was tasked by rove
with uh prosecuting uh
what rove calls voter fraud
and
to find people who are fraudulently
registered to vote
and he investigated for several months
and he said it's not happening it
doesn't exist
and as a result of that he lost his job
and the brennan center at nyu has done
very
nyu school of law has done thorough
investigation of the idea of voter fraud
and they say basically it doesn't exist
there have been
10 or 12 cases in the first 10 years
of this century
out of hundreds of millions of votes
it's someone may register as mickey
mouse but mickey mouse never shows up in
votes
so to spend but nevertheless rove has
initiated a campaign and it's it's alive
in more than 30 state legislatures
of having votes
requiring voter ids
now a lot of the democrats are saying
that this is basically a form of voter
suppression that is it it uh in many
cases you find the elderly who who've
given up their driver's licenses they
voted for 50 years but now they no
longer have a government-issued id so
they're not allowed to vote
you have minorities and particularly
hispanics
one of the challenges the republicans
face
is the hispanic time bomb there are 50
million hispanics to the united states
now they'll be 70 million in 2020. if
they start to vote on mass it's going to
be curtains for the republicans there
are 10 million hispanics in texas alone
states like texas and arizona
will flip from red to blue very soon uh
once that that kicks in so this is one
thing they're trying to do and this is
uh was at rose
behest starting ten years ago uh to
suppress the vote and uh if these go
were to go through in all the states it
would disenfranchise
21 million registered voters or eligible
voters rather
so uh
before opening this
to questions i i i think uh
we're now going to see what rove will do
with this one billion dollars plus
over the next
seven or eight weeks
and uh
he is a master at creating
a narrative that doesn't always exist if
you look at the swift boat scandal again
uh this was scrift wrote veterans for
truth in 2004 that was his last election
it was enormously effective
roe said he had absolutely nothing to do
with it but of course when you go back
and it takes months to do this and you
figure out
where the money came from it came from
the same donors he's been using for 30
years from uh
people like
bob perry who's a texas billionaire
harold simmons another texas billionaire
and so forth and now
he's made sort of his allegiance
with the tea party and he's got people
like the koch brothers who will put in
as much as 400 million dollars into this
election
uh
uh sheldon adelson will put in as much
as a hundred million dollars
and uh we will see him go to work over
the next two months
so
thank you and
[Applause]
i guess we can have some questions now
and i should say this is on c-span so uh
this is being televised and be careful
what you say i guess
yes
i enjoyed listening to you earlier in
the week on leonard lopate and
developed a few questions from that
microphone
oh so um one
do you have any idea about who pays karl
rove and how much he gets paid and two
i'm really worried about ohio are you in
terms of voter support well ohio is
always an uh and
yeah
the question was
how does he get paid and and how much
and who pays him uh and the second
question is what about ohio
uh you know
obviously he's on fox news's payroll in
the wall street journal's payroll and he
makes a a and
peanuts for him maybe but not not for me
um but he's uh uh you know when you
raise a billion dollars and and uh there
are millions and millions in contracts
going out to be perfectly honest it is
impossible for me to trace that money
there's no question there are people
that um
uh the media buyers the and makers the
strategists who who make a lot of money
uh he claims he does not take a piece of
that i honestly don't know the answer to
that for sure one thing i found out i
mean it's a little off point but
when i looked at who works for him how
does he operate
uh what i found is the people who are
karl rove operatives
are not on its payroll they get paid
they find a way to get paid and when
you're
in the white house when george w bush
was in the white house
uh it was very easy for them to get
contracts say from fema the federal
emergency management agency
and uh those contracts are given out at
the last minute with very little
oversight they're they're given out
obviously in the case of an emergency
and uh in return for a lucrative
contract people will operate uh all year
long as operatives for rove
um yes i'm sorry
you talked about the suppression of the
vote yet you need id to go on a plane
you need an id to get into the
democratic convention so why should you
not need an id to vote well being a
consumer or being a a traveler is very
different than being a citizen and and i
i've heard this i mean the the real
question is
i mean we're supposed to be a democracy
and you have universal suffrage do you
why should you need an
uh
this is a government-issued id mind you
that means like a driver's license we
don't have uh formal government-issued
uh ids in this country
uh except driver's license is only one i
have
um
but but the the real reason is it
disenfranchises uh millions of people
that is why should an elderly person
who's given up his driver's license
therefore be disenfranchised
people have an opportunity to issue ids
by the state you can get an id if you
have to get one how do you go on a plane
they you don't have no you don't the
requirement to vote isn't that you have
to travel or go on a plane the
requirement boat is merely your citizen
why add on additional strictures
the only reason it is is enfranchised
people
thought about it
right yeah i'm sorry
[Music]
but you make this country sound like
russia or afghanistan
and and the corruption
and um
the uh eliminating of the right to vote
i mean somebody's been voting at the
same precinct for 50 years and they go
down there and they don't have an id
they know each other intimately but the
law says they need an id it's observed i
find the fraud on
karl rove and his buddy's side
horrendous
and there's been so little voter fraud
reported in all the research right
well thank you
i'm not sure what to say about that but
[Laughter]
uh
yes and sir
is carl
at the top of the pyramid or is he just
the top lieutenant for someone else no
he he's very much a power
of his own making and what's what's
extraordinary about him is he operates
almost he he has effectively swallowed
the republican party
he is more powerful in some ways than
the rnc now there's a schism within the
party the tea partiers and the old
establishment which is small in his rove
and ed gillespie and some uh hangers on
from the bush era
he tries to discipline people you can
see him
in the 2010 election uh christine
o'donnell was the tea party senatorial
candidate in delaware who uh talked
about dabbling in witchcraft he did not
like that and he came down on her uh
likewise with todd aiken the tea party
candidate in
in missouri who talked about legitimate
rape uh
rove didn't like that and if you look at
the finances there you can see rose
power aiken had raised 2.2 million
dollars uh rov's american crossroads had
put in 15 million dollars in that senate
race
and as soon as aiken said that the rug
came out and he pulled it out and now
he he he's trying to oust a and very
strongly aikens hanging in there but uh
in return rove uh i i was sort of
surprised he uh last week he said if
aiken ends up murdered don't come
looking for me
uh yes
why did michael still get fired really
well well he
he was uh you know why the question is
why was michael steele pushed out of the
republican party and the answer is uh he
couldn't raise any money at all and in
terms of style he was trying to make it
sort of a hip-hop party and that didn't
quite work uh with country club
republicans or the tea party for that
matter
um
he uh
it it just yeah i mean
it was really a funny question what were
they
whether was he trying to go up against
obama he was not going to bring african
americans into the party he was turning
off the party base and nothing was
happening he simply couldn't raise any
money
so uh yes
yeah there's a woman no the
i have a two-part question one is do you
think there ever was a time in this
country
when our government was more
honorable
or is it simply that we have become more
and more sophisticated so the
shenanigans are ever more elaborate and
enormous and the second part of the
question is would getting rid of the
electoral college in any way help us out
well i mean i i personally would love to
get rid of the electoral college and and
it would eliminate
uh something like ohio being so central
i mean it's it's when you're here in new
york no one cares about how new york
votes it's for democrats so you let so
they just don't care about us and our
vote doesn't mean as much as a vote in
ohio it really doesn't uh and the
attention on ohio is extraordinary when
you go there and
as to the first question uh you know i
think what's amazing is the amount of
money and that um when you go back
when you look at the supreme court
decision on uh citizens united it was
quite extraordinary and i think one of
the you you see the language being
butchered again and again
uh in an orwellian way because the
ruling was meant to give a voice and and
now i'm quoting to a deprived
and disadvantaged class of people
like the koch brothers
like sheldon adelson and it's just uh
uh
you know and i think the founders had no
idea about uh buying up
uh niche markets and the airwaves in in
ohio uh about in about
facebook and social media and the
internet and so forth so and and that
kind of money simply wasn't an issue but
going all the way back to the
beginning things printed in the
newspapers about i don't know jackson or
oh absolutely absolutely so it was
smaller because we didn't have facebook
and it seems to me that it's been
crooked almost from the beginning we're
just bigger well there were horrible
things lies about abraham lincoln and
there were and and
likewise there have been horrible lies
about um that
rose opponents in one election after
another
so is it only in our imagination that we
imagine that this really is a democracy
where we wish wish to i mean is it
really is that just as uh
you know well
and i i can't speak to all of american
history but it's just uh
you know yeah yeah
i'd like to know how karl rove got
started where what
how did he get started where was he born
and how did he get into such a position
right well as a kid when when some of us
were worshiping mickey mantle or johnny
united he was studying william mckinley
and mckinley's operative uh mark hannah
who put mckinley in the white house and
he calls himself a classic nerd and in
college he was on the college
republicans he ran for executive
director of uh college of republicans
and his campaign manager was a legendary
lee atwater who
was the real bad boy of the republican
party he did the famous willie horton ad
in the 1988 campaign
uh for
the elder george bush uh and uh i when
when
uh
when atwater died of a brain tumor at
the age of 40 and that opened up a space
for karl rove and i think that's where
he really took off but but it's also
instructive that he he worked for nixon
during watergate and he was investigated
by the fbi rove was in his early 20s
during the watergate era and the fbi
kind of dropped it because they had
other fish to fry
uh but uh even back then he was doing
dirty tricks
yeah
with a billion dollars in his hands what
um
shenanigans do you see him possibly
doing in the next
week
there's no question a huge amount of
money will be going into uh the airwaves
and it if romney implodes and he's had a
very bad week you'd see roves shifting
all
his attention to taking over the senate
but but i also think rove has been a
great uh
ambassador at creating a narrative and
getting it out there a counter narrative
and uh i'm looking at while i was i was
in the democratic convention in
charlotte north carolina and there were
ads on tv from a group called special
operations opsec
and uh we will see if that turns into
the swift vote veterans for truth of
this uh
this campaign also with the events in
libya and the middle east unfolding uh
you know you can watch nbc and say oh
romney's completely falling apart but
let me suggest you turn the channel to
fox and you and you'll get a completely
different narrative and with a billion
dollars to fill up the airwaves that
that uh can be built into something that
has real resonance
and uh that obama's weak in the middle
east and so forth uh even
uh the the ads i saw in north carolina
where i mean rove is uh one of his his
great
uh tactics is to attack
his opponent's strength and these ads
were attacking obama
over the killing of osama bin laden
where you think he'd be vulnerable but
they were making it into leaked security
leaks
from the obama administration were
making us vulnerable
um
what i find disturbing is the following
i understand that you wrote a book about
a boss rove and therefore you want to
bring out
information about him that you find is
unfavorable
but in this discussion at least
there was no um
no discussion at all
that maybe the democratic party is
for lack of a better word just as
corrupt
we all know about the corruption of mr
soros
or at least the monies that he's
spending which you don't even bother to
discuss
we also know about the corruption of
chicago politics
and we also know and i'll tell you the
truth this is a this is an incident
which disturbs me more than anything
when there were black panthers
not allowing white people to go in to
vote in a certain election and i it was
recent it wasn't too long ago okay there
was real there was wait a moment there
was there was absolutely okay so my
question is all right if you want okay
all right so if you want a question i
will give you a question
why are you not presenting
an unbiased view in both respects
because because
be all right
well
but but you are okay you're making him
to be the worst person and he's not
because the corruption exists on the
other side as well okay i i mean
if you find any inaccuracies in my book
i'll gladly address them but i don't
think they're i mean i i'm not aware of
any
i just suggest
you write is about sorrows
yes
do you believe that there is anything
that could be done to turn this around
or has it got gotten totally away from
us at this point
uh
you know you know
the question was is there anything that
can be done to turn this around and i i
do think the citizens united
decision does open the floodgates and
and
and that
to me it's crazy for the united states
supreme court
the if you read the decision the basis
is it's a first amendment case
uh that we're this is being done and i'm
not uh you can read read it it's written
by justice anthony kennedy to give voice
to the deprived and disadvantaged
and it seems crazy to me
that a billion dollars
doesn't amplify the voice of
billionaires so much that it drowns out
everyone else's voice uh in terms of
redressing that uh
it requires the supreme court to reverse
it or perhaps a constitutional amendment
that's very very difficult
so yeah and
do you think there's a possibility of a
backlash
if he comes out with 1.8 billion dollars
worth of stuff that is rammed down our
throats for the next seven weeks
is there any hope
of a backlash
that it will that will overplay yourself
you know i don't know but the thing is
it it
when you travel around this country a
bit you see how uh fragmented it is and
new york is not really part of the
united states i mean i'm on that west
side i've lived here
and uh
this when when you're in uh
the
the heartland in the battleground states
and and your only source of information
or these ads and fox news it's a very
very different world
craig perhaps you could talk a little
bit about how karl rove
managed the republican primaries and
had a kind of puppet master
touch on what was really going on with
the republican candidates right well
well it was interesting to see rove
plays two roles of course he's a talking
head on fox news and and he works for
the wall street journal uh and and i
thought oh he's playing he's uh isn't
there a conflict there well the truth is
he was really
here you saw the party boss in action
and essentially he was picking off one
candidate after another
everyone except romney and it would be
first sarah palin uh who uh was so
stunned she didn't even declare
candidacy
uh he he took care of newt gingrich
rick santorum
rick perry
uh
herman cain he made fun of all of them
again and again and again
and when he does that on fox news he's
not just a talking head he's the party
boss saying look i've got a billion
dollars you're not getting any of it
you're not going to run you're not going
to be the nominee and and you know
romney never took off during the
primaries he never took off during the
primaries uh
he it was simply everyone else was
picked off one at a time
so yeah
anyway
i arrived late but um
to what extent uh
it's not just a problem with with the
republicans but what with uh
uh ralph nader used to call in oh oh uh
the republicans
and maybe for every
car road there is
less efficient democrat trying
efforts like al gore's america blah blah
do not
do not really touch a nerve in the
american public so maybe as carville
would say it is the public is stupid
but i'm sorry what is the question my
point is that it's not just a republican
right-wing uh ultra right-wing problem
but the democrats also
are embedded in money and it's only that
they are less successful
yeah well
well i mean i i think the question is
aren't they all the same is that really
roughly what you're getting at and and i
i do think there's there are fundamental
differences and and i would use the u.s
u.s attorney scandal is is just to give
you one example
this is a very serious issue when the
law is used to prosecute just one group
of people when there's elective
prosecution that's very very serious and
the case of don siegelman is important
not just for his
personal pain of having to go to jail
but uh because you see
the law being used to uh ruin the queers
of hundreds of democrats really
and once
a law is used just for democrats going
to be used just against blacks or
hispanics or or other groups uh that
that's a very serious blow to democracy
i think
[Applause]
um
yes in in the back there i just want to
address the
the lady who was talking earlier about
why you didn't uh choose to write about
george soros and why you just write
about karl rove so really my responses
to her um
you know if you want to read about
george soros and you want a negative uh
portrayal of him you can find one uh you
can uh the david horowitz book what is
it uh shadows or something like that i
mean there are plenty of books that will
support your point of view
an author is not obliged to include
every point of view he chose to write
about karl rove maybe at the end of his
reporting it would have been a
fabulously positive portrayal it didn't
turn out that way but he's under no
obligation
to give you both sides of the story he's
only obliged to write about what his
subject is and i think that if you want
to hear
you know the story that you seem to want
to hear
you should seek out those authors i
think that's a perfectly fair thing to
do
yeah the
man and
i can't think of his name now but the
republican power broker that got the
guys the uh
the uh congressmen and senators assigned
i will never vote for a tax increase nor
grover norquist what is his relationship
with rove they're friendly they're
they're close
they work together
yeah
um
and
one more question uh
um yeah
are there more of these who are other
journalists who are kind of on your side
or who who are likely to
help get this story out
no well there there were actually a
couple of uh
reporters in texas wayne slater and
james bohr who did uh good books early
on on rove and i mean the only thing is
i thought it was worth going back to
because i think a lot of people thought
he was finished
with the 08 election and here i saw the
deed at second life
so
thank you
[Applause]
we'd like to hear from you tweet us your
feedback twitter.com
booktv